a fisherman wipes fuel office boat he
says it's from the oil tanker that sank
on Tuesday in the central Philippines
close by Philippine Coast Guards are
placing Booms to contain the spill the
governor of the province of Oriental
mindoro says its unrefined Fuel and the
ship had 800 000 liters of it
the marine environment protective unit
has confirmed that it is coming already
from the ifo industrial fuel oil what is
worse is this morning's report that was
given by PCG that the amount of fuel
industrial fuel that is leaking
monitored it the other day it is a rate
of 200 liters per minute
the oil spill has reached the
neighboring island of antique that's
about 130 kilometers from where the oil
tanker capsized in many fear it's
getting closer to the resort island
Boracay that's seen as the crown jewel
of Philippine tourism
is more to the east of the wind
direction
so if the question is if will it reach
my answer is we have a very slim chance
even if Baraka is spared however the
damage to marine life is likely to be
immense
over there that's where the island and
this whole area has one of the most
diverse marine ecosystems in the world
we're not far from where the oil tanker
sank and the fear is that the oil may
have drifted to Marine protected areas
like this
with the oil spills spreading fast and
wide scientists estimate 20 000 hectares
of coral reefs may be affected that's an
area the size of a city Governor Dolores
says the problem must be stopped at the
source
I have directed the owner of the ship
the vessel and the Philippine Coast
Guard to immediately deploy their
sunking equipment
sucking equipment because once the
sucking equipment is able to remove the
oil then the further spread from the
elite will be stopped
coast guards say they don't have the
specialist equipment needed to prevent a
disaster
but the governor says the owner of the
vessel must find a way or suffer legal
consequences
Barn below Al Jazeera Oriental mindoro
the Philippines